when the platypus first came to the
attention of european scientists in 1798
not everyone was convinced that the
creature before them was even
real some thought a prankster had mashed
together
separate parts of different animals to
create a fake
not an uncommon occurrence at this boom
time of natural discovery
but the platypus was a very real animal
and one that confused anatomists for
some time
a creature with fur a bill and webbed
feet
that lays eggs and can secrete venom was
this a mammal
a duck some sort of furry reptile
these european scientists were asking
the same questions that the aboriginal
people of australia had been asking for
a long time
before them there are several aboriginal
stories about the origins of the
platypus
one of which tells of a union between a
duck and a water rat
in science terms we've ultimately
classed the platypus as a mammal or more
specifically
a monotreme an egg-laying mammal of
which there are only two kinds of
animals in the world
and this along with its other rather
reptilian traits
has made scientists scratch their heads
for a long time
where does the platypus fit exactly on
the tree of life
as continents divided and the branches
of the tree of life diverged
the platypus seems to have taken its own
very special route
but just like with all animal
adaptations there has to be some purpose
to all the platypus's strangeness
but what evolutionary question was this
the right answer to
if you look back in any textbook the
definition of a mammal is a warm-blooded
vertebrate animal that has fur
secretes milk and typically gives birth
to live young
typically being the key word there
platypuses are one of only two mammals
that lays eggs
the other is the only other monotreme
the echidna
of which there are four species when
it's time to lay the eggs
female platypuses dig their burrows
crawl in and seal themselves up
here they lay their eggs curling them
between body and tail
until they hatch 10 days later from here
the platypus acts like most other
mammals
nursing their young on milk for three to
four months until they're capable of
swimming solo
to understand how and why this
egg-laying ability exists in a mammal
we need to wind back the clock a long
long time
around 340 million years ago the first
amniotes appeared on earth
in the form of small lizard-like
creatures amniotes are four-legged
vertebrates that are defined by the
membrane or amnion that protects the
embryo during development
the amniotic egg was an evolutionary
invention that first allowed reptiles to
colonize
dry land fish and amphibians must lay
their eggs in water and therefore can't
live far from water
but thanks to the amniotic egg reptiles
can lay their eggs nearly anywhere on
dry land
soon amniotes spread far and wide around
earth's land and became the dominant
land vertebrates
and around 315 million years ago
they split into the two major groups of
four-legged vertebrates which still
exist
today one branch contains the modern
reptiles and birds
the other included the mammal-like
reptiles from which modern mammals later
evolved
this branch of mammals eventually
developed to have the amniotic egg grow
inside the mother's womb
giving rise to internal pregnancies but
one branch of mammals did not follow
suit
the monotremes or egg-laying mammals
split off from the mammalian lineage
around 200 million years ago
they never gained the ability to have an
internal pregnancy
and never lost their egg laying ability
genome sequencing of platypus sex cells
have shown there are a large number of
shared genes between platypuses and
birds
in particular the platypus retains
copies of the vitella ginnin gene
which codes for egg protein that is a
precursor to egg yolk
which in turn helps sustain growing
embryos
platypuses have fewer copies of the gene
than birds in reptiles
but most mammals don't have the gene at
all
this means the platypus has the ability
to lay eggs
but that their young are perhaps less
reliant on egg protein than birds and
reptiles
this makes sense when we remember that
platypuses also feed their young via
lactation
after hatching their laying of eggs is a
sort of
hangover from their reptilian ancestors
and for a while
it served them well the monotremes were
the dominant mammals on what is now the
continent of australia
for a long time that is until they got
swept aside by the arrival of their
marsupial cousins
marsupials originated in what is now
south america
and migrated over to what is now
australia via the
supercontinent gondwana around 70
million years ago
their bodies were more efficient at
locomotion and their internal
pregnancies meant they could better
protect their young
and thus they out-competed the
monotremes on almost every front
and slowly all but two the echidna and
the platypus
went extinct so the question is why did
they survive
when the rest did not
one hypothesis as to how the platypus
persisted in the face of intense
competition from the marsupials
is its ability to take to the water a
domain where the marsupials could not
follow the echidna's earlier ancestor
too
is thought to have been semi-aquatic
even though it's not anymore
marsupials could not colonize water
environments because when they're born
they have to live inside their mother's
pouch for weeks to suckle milk
the babies would drown if their mothers
ever had to venture into the water
but with their eggs secure in a nest the
platypus can happily stay in the water
avoiding predation from the marsupials
and exploiting
their very own environmental niche the
platypus is an expert swimmer
its ability to hunt below the water is
down to a few
key features of its physiology the
platypus's webbed feet help power them
through the water
using their front feet for paddling
their back feet for steering
and a feature that helps the platypus
stay submerged for up to two minutes at
a time is its ability to become
watertight when necessary it has folds
of skin that cover its ears and it can
close its nostrils too
and despite its hunting prowess
underwater it nearly completely closes
its eyes when diving
thanks to a sixth sense that almost no
other mammal possesses
it doesn't need to see to hunt
one of the most distinct parts of the
platypus is its bill
its iconic shape is wide and flat but
unlike a duck spill the platypus bill is
described as flexible
rubbery and a little fleshy its surface
supposedly feels a bit like
suede and the bill is the platypus's
primary hunting tool
it can hunt with its eyes completely
closed
because it's super sensitive in two key
ways
it's mechanoreceptive and
electroreceptive
mechanoreceptive means sensitive to
external mechanical stimulus such as
touch
or pressure in the case of the platypus
its bill contains mechanoreceptors
called push rods
these are columns of densely packed
cells that move
independently of surrounding skin when
pressure or a vibration is applied to
the push rod
it triggers the nerve at the bottom of
the column
the pressure doesn't have to be large
the slightest tremors can be felt
through the water
the bill is so sensitive it can detect
fresh water shrimp from a distance of 15
to 20 centimeters away simply by sensing
movements in the water
the other sensing ability of the bill is
its electro-reception
all animals emit electric signals from
their muscles when moving
and the platypus bill can sense these
electric fields originating from their
prey
the bill contains around 70 000 glands
that assist in the electroreceptive
function of the bill
the mechanism of electroreception in the
bill is much like that of the
elasmobranks
like the hammerhead shark the electrical
currents from the stimulus
travel through the water and then
through secretions from the glands in
the bill
which surround nerve endings beneath the
bill's surface
the one hundred thousand electro and
mechanoreceptors on the platypus bill
are arranged in a beautiful striped
pattern with bands of electro and
mechanoreceptors alternating
electroreception is common in fish but
has only been found
in three mammals to date the platypus
the echidna
and the guyana dolphin platypus bills
have up to 70
000 electro receptors and those of long
build and short build echidnas have only
2
and 400 respectively you can see
evolution in progress here
since moving back onto land the electro
receptors of the echidnas are being
selected against
because such sensing ability is only
useful in semi-aquatic environments
but this electroreception is not a
remnant from an early
fishier ancestor it evolved completely
independently of electric fish
and is the answer two different lineages
came up with to a similar evolutionary
pressure
electroreception isn't the only feature
of the platypus that's rarely seen in
mammals
next time you pick up a platypus you'd
be wise to keep its back legs pointing
out of reach
male platypuses have spurs on the back
of their hind feet that connect to venom
glands in their abdomen
and that while not deadly to humans can
have some pretty nasty side effects
nausea cold sweats lymph nodes swelling
and immediate excruciating pain that
can't be relieved through normal
painkillers
venomous mammals are now pretty rare
there are only a handful that we know of
such as the slow loris the only known
venomous primate
which uses venom to protect itself
against predators
or the american short-tailed shrew which
uses its venom to immobilize its insect
prey
it's thought that with the development
of teeth and claws
most mammals developed much faster ways
of killing prey than venom
which needs time to take effect and so
venomous capabilities became
evolutionarily redundant of the mammals
that kept their venom
the very different methods of delivery
suggest the ability evolved
independently
take the slow lorises mentioned earlier
they can look pretty cute when they
raise their arms in the air as if
they're asking for a hug
but don't be fooled this is actually how
they access their venom
it's produced by glands in their armpits
which they lick
the venom mixes with their saliva and
settles into grooves in their teeth
ready to harm anything that the slow
loris bites
the short-tailed shrew also has grooves
in its teeth
but its venom comes ready made in the
shrew's saliva
both of which differ to the platypus
which delivers its venom
through its spurs but interestingly for
the platypus
a recent study found that many of the
proteins present
in its venom are the same as those found
in reptile venom
even though the reptiles split from
mammals some 315 million years ago
does this mean the venom is an
evolutionary leftover from the
platypus's reptilian ancestor
or is it an example of independent
convergent evolution of the venom
by sequencing the platypus genome
scientists found that the platypus's
ability to deliver venom is down to a
duplication in a set of reptilian genes
the same reptilian genes that underwent
the same duplication
independently in snakes after reptiles
and mammals split
in the evolutionary tree this suggests
then
that platypus venom is an unlikely
example of convergent evolution
in this case reptiles and the platypus
developed
similar venoms despite not having a
common ancestor for hundreds of
millions of years scientists still don't
know
exactly why platypuses have venom spurs
but it's thought that they use them in
mating practices
and to defend territory inmates from
other platypuses
despite its weirdness we now understand
that the platypus is not just a
funny-looking animal
it's a highly adapted creature perfectly
suited to its environment
some of its bizarre features are
remnants from an ancient
time and others are more recent
evolutionary inventions
that happen to be similar to ones in the
fish the birds and the reptiles
it's a wild and unlikely mashup of
traits that allows the platypus to sit
on its very own branch of the
evolutionary tree
but we also know there's a lot more of
the puzzle to put together
scientists are constantly stumbling
across new
unusual findings about this amazing
animal
just last year researchers accidentally
discovered that platypus skin
glows under uv light why we still don't
know
there are likely many more secrets
hiding within the platypus
that we will continue to discover for
years to come
australia's unique landscape and
geography made the platypus what it is
today
australia is literally teeming with
biodiversity
its patchwork of different climates from
tropical forests to hostile deserts to
tropical reefs
along with its isolated nature has given
rise to some of the world's strangest
and most iconic
creatures eighty percent of the plants
and animals in australia are unique to
australia
found nowhere else on earth having grown
up in america
australia's animals seem downright alien
to me
and i love learning about their
evolution and their sometimes wacky
behavior
to immerse yourself in 50 minutes of the
beautiful
weird and wonderful australian continent
you should watch hidden australia on
curiosity stream
believe me i have spent my life watching
nature documentaries and this one still
showed me animals i never knew existed
like what even is this guy this is such
a fun film and will make you daydream
about getting to visit such an
incredible and diverse place
curiosity stream is a streaming platform
with thousands of high quality
documentaries like this one
and now curiosity stream has partnered
with us to offer an
incredible deal by signing up to
curiositystream you now
also get a subscription to nebula nebula
is a streaming platform made by me
and several other educational youtube
content creators
it's a place where we can upload our
videos and podcasts ad free
and a place where we can experiment with
new original content
by signing up to the bundle deal you'll
get access to both curiosity stream and
nebula where you can access originals
like joe scott's original series called
mysteries of the
human body with episodes like real human
oddities from history
or the strangest epidemics of all time
or you can watch braincraft's
questionable advice series
where vanessa meets creators who have a
problem that psychology
may be able to fix so by signing up at
curiositystream.com
real science you'll get a subscription
to curiosity stream and a subscription
to nebula for just 14.79 for the entire
year signing up is also the best way to
support this channel
and all of your favorite educational
content creators
and if you're looking for something else
to watch right now you can watch our
previous video about
talking trees or watch real
engineering's latest video
the truth about biofuels which discusses
and explains why the biofuel industry
isn't as green as we think it is